something strange happened with the war
in Ukraine
on the turn of a dime the entire
narrative from every Western Government
mainstream media and corporations went
from covet fear-mongering to Putin
fear-mongering all within the span of
pretty much a day all for a country
called Ukraine a country that before The
Invasion the majority of the US
population has never even heard of much
or less be able to point it out on a map
and let's be real 911 type events happen
pretty much every day in the Middle East
Africa and in poor Asian Nations every
day and no one cares
there's something deeper going on here
yes the warring Ukraine is wrong but
what's the incentive for all these
powerful people to care all of a sudden
what is the incentive for this hashtag
Stanwood Ukraine narrative which we
should be doing by the way I've actually
been to Ukraine before I care about the
place but you have to ask yourself who
stands to profit from helping Ukraine
and why is anyone who doesn't told the
party line under threat of getting
canceled well as always it turns out
that if you follow the money you'll find
the answer
there are many profiteers when it comes
to Ukraine from weapons manufacturers to
construction companies who have to
rebuild the country once it's over but
the one group that it comes down to the
wolf and sheep's clothing who pretends
to care but really stands to make the
most profits are the bankers
this is how you profit off of the war in
Ukraine while looking like a saint
as Russia is using against Ukraine isn't
a physical weapon but a digital one
armies are some of the most
sophisticated hackers in the world
aiming to shut down Ukraine's
infrastructure like their electrical
grid but you don't have to be a victim
of War to be targeted by hackers in fact
someone gets their identity stolen every
14 seconds with a more than 200 increase
in identity theft from 2019 to 2021 so
it's not a matter of if you're going to
be targeted by hackers but when and
that's where Aura comes in today's video
sponsor Aura basically left out all the
essential online security tools that you
need to be using in today's day and age
like identity death protection fraud
monitoring a VPN a password manager
antivirus software and put all of that
into one great all-in-one app that is
simple to use and just works saving you
a ton of money by not having to pay for
these apps separately and also saving
you a ton of money from the cybercraft
that they may prevent you from becoming
a victim to here is how it works you
sign up for Aura with the link below and
then you connect your bank account so or
I can monitor for suspicious
transactions and then you can connect
your credit score to Monitor and lock
your credit score with than the app then
you can start using their password
manager down their antivirus and VPN
software to automatically run scans on
your computer every day which is what I
do all the while Aura automatically
monitors for your personal info from
data sources like dark websites and
public records to protect you from
Identity thefts and whenever something
suspicious happens within all these
features like a suspicious transaction
for example or it will send you a text
straight to your phone they have a
family plan that protects up to five
people and they provide 24 7 customer
support every single day of the year
these tools are things everyone should
be using online without exception yet if
you pay for them all separately it will
cost a ton of money not with ore though
they want to make sure everyone can
afford to protect themselves so you get
all this basically for the price of
paying for one of these apps separately
and they even offer a 60-day money-back
guarantee and if you go to aura.com Jake
right now with the link below you'll get
Aura for free for two weeks that's
aura.com Jake for two weeks free thanks
to Oro for sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]
of public wealth to private hands in the
history of this Earth these days people
and the resources are controlled not by
viceroys and occupying armies but by
other more sophisticated means of which
the principal weapon is dead
effort and depths are exactly the same
thing except for one point which is that
nobody needs to occupy territory today
debt is one of the most subtle and
Powerful forms of imperialism in the
world sure to the world it looks like
these Bankers are offering a rose we're
giving Ukraine emergency relief but it's
not free money it's debts debt that has
to be paid back with interest and before
Ukraine this is how debt slavery would
normally be pitched let's say you've got
a massive construction or engineering
company that specializes in really big
projects like hydroelectric plants or
vital infrastructure you want more money
but there's a problem you see First
World countries have money but they
already have all the infrastructure they
need which leaves you trying to get
money from third world countries instead
the UN likes to call them least
developed countries or ldcs ldcs are the
perfect Market they don't have any
infrastructure and they probably don't
have companies with the expertise to
build them either you'll build their
rows and power plants and the people in
power in that poor country will get all
the credit for improving their Nation
but there's only one problem the are
least developed countries they don't
have the billions they would need to pay
you for these projects but that's where
the magic of debt in the form of foreign
aid comes in you see foreign aid is a
deceptive term for debts it makes it
seem like these really big banking
institutions are actually trying to help
and at least Americans saying oh look
we're doing so much to help these poor
Nations that's so nice of us but for the
most part humans especially those with
money and power don't really do things
out of the kindness of their hearts
there's always some ulterior motive and
that's not always a bad thing it's just
human nature and from the people
offering services like construction
foreign aid is their bread and butter
because suddenly the countries that
could never afford your hydroelectric
Planet suddenly can and you get a big
fat paycheck in return and the
politicians and Bakers who arrange the
foreign aid well they're just as happy
because the more debt ldcs take on the
harder it would be for them to repay it
and the more money they'll owe you the
best part about countries owing you
something you're the one calling the
shots these poor countries were invaded
in the traditional sense but the outcome
is functioning only the same the United
States says the report is capable and
willing to pursue important policy
objectives in the banks by exercising
the financial and political leverage at
our disposal all the while these Bankers
are swimming in future interest earnings
so you see burying countries in debt is
a brilliant way to enrich countries that
are already well off its imperialism 2.0
why waste time on Wars and invasions
that the public hates when you could
just get these countries to sign their
Futures away with smiles on their faces
all the while many of these
infrastructure projects end up being
unprofitable or poorly constructed
anyways but it doesn't matter because
they already signed the loan the world's
oldest human rights organization the
anti-slavery Society has declared that a
contemporary form of slavery nowhere is
this more vividly demonstrated than here
in the Philippines where 44 of the
national budget is given to paying
interest charges to foreign Banks one
Filipino child dies every hour
because of the increase in debt service
payments debt has been
[Music]
traditionally done but what about
war-torn countries how do bankers profit
off of a country at War well as an
international banking institution this
is how you apply debt imperialism to
Ukraine
and on top of it we have Russia's
invasion of Ukraine devastating for
people in Ukraine but also
step number one show some solidarity you
need to make the world believe that you
genuinely care about Ukraine and you
only have their best interests at Hearts
we will limit Russia's ability to do
business in dollars Euros pounds and Yen
we're joining with European allies to
find and seize their Yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill begotten gains
send out PR people condemn Russia slap
sanctions on the oligarch of the day and
make sure everyone knows just how
anti-putin you really are then appeal to
the people of Ukraine tell them they
have your full supports make them think
you're completely on their side for this
to work the world has to believe that
you're acting in the best interest of
the Ukrainian people today I'm
announcing another 800 million dollars
to further augment Ukraine's ability to
fight in the east in the donbos region
light will win over Darkness
Ukrainian Ambassador the United States
is here tonight sitting with the First
Lady
lets each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world of Ukraine
thank you as an example just copy what
the international monetary fund or IMF
and the World Bank already said about
Ukraine we are deeply shocked and
saddened by the devastating human and
economic toll brought by the war in
Ukraine people are being killed injured
forced to flee and massive damage is
caused to the country's physical
infrastructure we stand with the
Ukrainian people through these
horrifying developments translated from
PR speak we'll keep you in our prayers
but we're actually not going to do
anything out of our way to help because
if the IMF and World Bank really did
care they would probably start by wiping
out all of Ukraine's 22 billion dollars
in debts owed to those same Bankers that
would have helped free out the
government's finances to help ukrainians
in need
foreign
[Music]
but that is not the priority right now
you have a much much better way to help
not just foreign aid but emergency aid
Ukraine has a lot of borders with
Romania with Moldova we have programs in
those countries that can be added to
support the uh the refugee flow
step number two offer financial
assistance in 1991 Ukraine was one of
the poorest Soviet territories and
didn't get much better even after the
fall of the USSR Ukraine was still seen
as an underachiever over the years
Ukraine has had to rely more and more on
foreign aid to get by but War when a
country is at War they will do anything
for cash why because war is ungodly
expensive Wars often bankrupt Nations or
destroy their currencies because of the
money printing there are guns to buy
vehicles to buy soldiers to pay
hospitals to maintain an infrastructure
to rebuild if it's a choice between
getting destroyed versus surviving in
debt they're gonna send a loan every
single time and that's why war is the
perfect time to saddle a country in
debts so you offer them emergency aid
and then you shout from the rooftops
about how moral and generous you are for
giving them not alone but Aid and with
all that new money there are a whole lot
more strings attached even though
Ukraine already owes billions in foreign
debts the IMF has given it another 1.8
billion Emergency Loan and the World
Bank added another almost 600 million
dollars in loans too while not forgiving
a single penny of their existing debts
even if the war stops right now Ukraine
is going to need a lot of time to
rebuild and get the economy going so how
would it be expected to pay back almost
2 billion dollars in loans plus
interests on top of its already existing
20 billion dollars plus in foreign debts
on average the IMF charges Ukraine 9 in
total charges and interest on their
loans so after a few years Ukraine will
have to pay back an extra 126 million
dollars on their 1.4 billion dollar loan
and the World Bank in 2020 they charge
Ukraine 14 in interest on average that
means they would make 82 million dollars
on their 600 million dollar loan for a
country with a GDP of just 150 billion
dollars before the war that would be a
lot to ask but now with so many
ukrainians leaving the country and
economic activity halted it is almost
impossible but don't let that bother you
because you know what as long as Ukraine
misses payments or creates new payment
plans you get to add more and more fees
and shared charges that will eventually
earn you Millions but it's not like
Ukraine has years before it needs to
make its next payments just this year it
has 7.3 billion dollars due more than
all the money is spent on education in a
year going into the pockets of his Loan
Sharks but at least for you life
couldn't get any better because the
benefits of offering Ukraine financial
aid don't just stop with the millions
you make in profits oh no there is
something even better in it for you
[Music]
Ukraine needs money so badly you can get
away with telling them to do pretty much
anything in return for decades loans
from the IMF and World Bank have come
with some serious strings attached
strings in the form of policy changes
every time International lenders offer
Ukraine money they add a few things they
want change to the Fine prints like
better conditions for international
investors the regulation of Industries
reducing government subsidies more
profitization of state-owned companies
anything you think might make your
business in Ukraine easier and more
profitable just add it to the Fine
prints and watch them sign their freedom
away and what countries control the IMF
and the World Bank why the United States
of course with the US controlling a
whopping 70 of the voting power in the
IMF these loans and their subsequent
policy changes becomes a sneaky way to
influence the regime in power to be
pro-us after all when you're being
bombed and shot at when you desperately
need money to fight back the last thing
on your mind are those pesky terms and
conditions at the bottom of the page
foreign
and the world would roll over instead he
met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met the
Ukrainian people
this man
Chester United
step number four encourage the war the
fight between good and evil is as old as
Humanity itself it plays out in the
tales we told around the campfire in our
religions in our superhero movies today
people love a good Hero vs villain story
and this is the Primal Instinct you want
to tap into so you want to make sure the
world follows the fear-mongering
narrative we talked about earlier Putin
is pure evil zielinski is pure good by
supporting Ukraine with foreign aid
you're helping good overcome evil make
sure that anything that goes wrong in
Ukraine is Putin's faults Putin is the
aggressor
Putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
all the new debt Ukraine has well it
wouldn't have happened if Putin didn't
invade Ukraine is struggling to make his
payments Russia's fault obviously make
sure that all that hate and anger is in
only of Vladimir Putin so that you can
keep scoring over the Ukrainian people
in the background
[Music]
foreign
asking you to forgive Ukraine's debts
just tell them your hands are tied if
you canceled Ukraine's debts every poor
country in the world will want to do the
same and then you'd have no money to
help anyone forcing Ukraine to pay is
only fair and you know what if Ukraine
can't make all their payments you'll be
happy to restructure their debt payments
or loan them even more money to pay off
their current payments
step number six enslave the nation no
matter which way the war goes Ukraine
will end up enslaved either obviously
through the control of Russia or
unobviously through the control of the
West Via International financial
institutions like the IMF which is just
a fancy term for Bankers enslavement of
Ukraine by Russia is out in the open and
it goes against all of our Western
ideals of democracy and freedom so the
West stands in solidarity against this
enslavement through Western debt however
is much more subtle but the result in
terms of control is functionally the
same it's still enslaving either way but
at least there's no direct balance in
the first two months of the invasion
Ukraine paid almost 700 million dollars
to its creditors money that could have
gone to help the people of Ukraine if
their foreign debt was forgiven instead
Ukraine had to promise it will keep
paying his debt on time with the help of
you guessed it financial assistance from
International institutions the same
institutions that will come knocking for
their money plus interests in a few
years time when the public might forget
about Ukraine and moves on to the next
outcry
[Music]
it's Jake and we make documentaries just
like this one every single week on money
power and crime so make sure you click
that subscribe button if you want longer
documentaries that are too controversial
to be posted publicly click that join
button below and if you join if you
don't think it's worth it there's a
refund policy so you can just email me
and I will send you the money back you
can follow me on Instagram at jtrend.io
that's going to wrap it up thank you so
much for watching stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]